this is an oem iPhone cable and then
this one is uh the OMG cable there's a
ton of system packed into this little
plastic end end piece here that allows
you to connect you can connect to it
wirelessly and then exfiltrate data you
can take control of any machine that so
if I gave this to you and I said hey I
need to charge my uh my airpods really
quick functions perfectly as a charger
does so you know charging my airpods
there you can see the uh Orange Circle
and you can extract whatever you want as
well correct so even if it's an air gap
machine it's never been on the internet
before I can basically type in the
commands that will allow it to store
that data for me and then I can zip it
back out when I need to I keep saying
this you guys are
dangerous